what wisdom
about parenting can you can you give
from your own experience and from your
writing
yeah well
oh my god there's a lot to say
so on the
bittersweet side of things the wisdom
that i would give is
that
especially for kids who are growing up
in relative comfort with everything
going pretty well
um
they get the idea
that
real life is when things are going well
and when things don't go well it's like
a detour from the main road
as opposed to understanding that it's
all the main road um and i i tell the
story in the book of
this time that
we went on this family vacation where we
rented a house in the countryside
and
the house was next to this field where
we're live two donkeys that our kids
fell in love with and they were like
really little at the time two boys
and
they're spending all this time feeding
carrots to the donkeys and it's all
beautiful and then comes the day where
they realize that we're leaving in like
two days and they're never going to see
these donkeys again and they start
crying themselves to sleep
and the usual things that
parents might say at a moment like that
of like you know maybe we'll come back
or another family will feed them we'll
feed these donkeys none of that made any
difference
but when we said to them
you know goodbye is part of life
and
this
this feeling you're having
everybody has it you've had it before
you're gonna have it again you'll feel
better in a couple days um
but this is the way it's supposed to be
this is natural that's when they stopped
crying because
i think that's when they stopped
resisting yeah
like it's one thing to feel the pain of
goodbye and it's another thing to be
feeling like this isn't supposed to be
happening
it's the resistance part of this isn't
supposed to be happening that makes life
really difficult
yeah as opposed to a more clear-eyed
view of what it really is this is indeed
supposed to be happening there's a show
called yellowstone recently started
watching yeah no i've heard of it we
actually started watching it but only a
few minutes and didn't get into it so
there's just a quick it's not a spoiler
of any kind but there's a father
taking out the sun for the first time to
go hunting and and
you know to shoot their first buck
and
the sons get really sad because he pulls
the trigger and he took a life
and the father says that
everybody gets killed in this life
that's the way of nature that's the way
uh each one of us is going to get killed
and
it's it's interesting because i didn't
really
think of it that way because you think
you die but he really framed it as
killed
because he's like
there's no such thing as dying of old
age let's medically let's discuss that a
bit but uh basically there's something
whether it's
a truck
uh or a bacteria
something's going to
kill you in the end
and that was an interesting way to look
at it because we tend to think of
humans aren't
aren't supposed to be killed we think of
murder as one of the sins sort of one of
the things that's you don't do in
society but you know what we do that's a
more technical discussion whether we
ultimately get killed by something in
the end
but it to some degree that's true at
least for most of us that there's
something that gets us whether it's
cancer
those kinds of things it's interesting
uh but yeah it's that reframing of it's
not it's supposed to be this is the way
of the world yeah
though it's funny i mean you know at the
same time then i just wrote a whole book
about the fact that
this is the way it is like i really do
believe this is the way it is and
and with this reality there's an intense
beauty that comes along with it
so we have to accept the reality to get
to the beauty i believe that and at the
same time there's a part of me that's
just like
yeah but give me the magic wand to make
the world different
yeah yeah yeah i don't know i don't know
how much of this is a female thing too
like i was watching with my son my 12
year old the other day we were watching
this show about the battle of
thermopylae um and
yeah and it was like all about you know
valor and glory on the battlefield
and um
and i said to him something like
gosh don't you just wish we lived in a
world where
you didn't have to do all this in order
for everyone just to live their lives
and he just looked at me completely
puzzled like
no you know like to him it all just
seemed self-evident that the world would
be structured that way you know and he
had like that the 12 year old
like admiration for the valor of it all
but you you wonder if that's um
if that's
nature and or nurture
i wonder what that world looks like
um it we do live in a world where murder
is seen as bad but you you look at a lot
of the human history
i don't know if they had the same kind
of conception of that
in terms of
you you have to ask what kind of murder
uh you know for what purpose you know
war was a way of life
um
it's interesting it's interesting if we
can imagine
properly
a future that is
different than ours in terms of
operating under the different moral
systems but i'd like
same with living um indefinitely
or living in a society with no war
like how fundamental is war how
fundamental is death
so fundamental to our source code i just
wish that our source code were different
basically like i can't get people i
can't get past that
there's there's brain computer
interfaces that try to merge
so greater and greater where smartphones
were already kind of cyborgs but greater
and greater merger of computational
power
so literally
adding source code to our original
source code just in a different there's
the mushy biology that runs source code
and then there's more cold
electrical
uh systems and then they integrate
together and potentially
one day we offload
the magic that is human consciousness
also into the machine and then we'll get
to see maybe maybe they'll be a little
bit less asshole-ish about the whole war
thing
that'd be more
but there is i think even when i engine
when i think about engineering
human intelligence or super human
intelligence systems i feel like they
also need to have the yin yang of life
they have to be able to be afraid and to
um to be sad and all those kinds of
things
but maybe it's because i'm
a product in this particular environment
maybe sadness is a human
useful human invention
but not a universal one this is what i
don't know because this is where i come
back to the
as i told you like the original reason
that i wrote my whole book was the
feeling that somehow in the expression
of sad music
is what
other people see when they talk about
god like there's something so
there's like an ultimate beauty there
yeah that i don't know if we have access
to without that but maybe we do
but i can say in this world it's a great
way to get
access to that state is it within the
reach of science to deeply understand
this you think
to understand that why you feel sad when
you're listening to a song or why you
feel so much love when you're listening
to a sad song
right yeah why
why the sad why the sad song opens up
some kind of
deep connection to something
you can call divine or something
whatever the heck that is yeah
i do think i mean we have like really
early
signs of it from the research and i'm
i'm sure we're just at the
scratching the surface stage but i mean
like we know for example that
um you know the vagus nerve which
is so fundamental that it governs our
breathing and our digestion
that our vagus nerve also activates when
we see another being in distress
there's like an instinctive impulse to
want to make it stop
um
and and the theory is that that's an
evolutionary design because we had to be
able to respond to
the cries of her infants you know and
from that ability it grows the
the greater ability to respond to other
people's cries too
so
that's probably just you know
like the very first step in being able
to understand what all that is
you